makeshift showers are the only escape
from the sweltering heat for these
children living in a refugee camp in
akar in Northern Lebanon temperatures
here have reached 42 degrees Celsius in
recent days
the heat has been brutal we have no
electricity no fans that's why we came
up with this idea of getting plastic
bags filling them with water and have
them sprinkle the water on the kids so
they can cool off and have fun food well
but at this camp like many others back
home in Syria there's not enough water
it's partly because of reduced support
from donor organizations
we don't even get water on a daily basis
it comes and goes we store the water
when it comes once or twice weekly and
we manage the best we can we want to
leave this camp but we don't know where
to go the heat is killing us
the 12-year Civil War has displaced 4.5
million people around 250 000 are in
akkar now soaring temperatures are
making conditions even tougher
we hope they find a solution for us we
need electricity water on a regular
basis not once a week we are struggling
the water tank is almost empty but we
are recycling this water for the kids
the children can do this twice a day in
the afternoon and evening their parents
say it helps prevent cases of heat
stroke and exhaustion but with more hot
weather forecasts they say they
desperately need additional supplies of
water Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera